statistically china is engaging in the
most rapid
re-militarization of any country in
absolute and relative terms in peacetime
[Music]
history hello and welcome to
trigonometry i'm francis foster i'm
constantine kissinger and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with fascinating people our terrific
guest today is a senior fellow at the
hudson institute and an expert on
southeast asian affairs dr john lee very
warm welcome all the way from australia
to trigonometry great thanks for having
me both of you uh it's a real pleasure
to have you on uh you some of the
interviews you've done and the
conversations you've had and the work
you've done on these issues is
absolutely fascinating can't wait to
talk to you about it but before we do
tell everybody a little bit about not
only what your areas of expertise are
which i've kind of hinted at but also
what is your personal journey through
life because i think it informs some of
the analysis and the perspectives that
you bring
yeah i
most of my career i've been in the think
tank world i spent a couple of years in
the australian government as the
national security advisor so
i was right in the middle of um
politics and policy for a little while i
still am i still deal with governments
quite a fair bit but
i'm back in the think tank world in
academic world i'm also an adjunct
professor at sydney university
um i uh as as you can probably tell from
uh my appearance i i was born in
southeast asia i was born in malaysia
i
my family migrated to australia when i
was very young about eight years old
um i've lived in australia i studied in
the united kingdom
um but most my career has been in
australia and the united states
um and it probably informs my
perspectives in in in many respects my
parents left malaysia
because they wanted a better life as
migrants do and we we went to australia
and and that is a typical immigrant
attitude has largely informed the way i
view
world affairs and the sorts of things
that i try to advocate uh in in my
career
and your analysis of china is absolutely
fascinating we want to talk to you about
the geopolitical situation post russia
invading ukraine and we'll have that
conversation in a second but the one
thing we francis and i both were just
incredibly fascinated by is your some of
the things you talk about the history of
china and the recent history of china
what the chinese learned from what
happened in russia in 1991 what the
chinese are learning now from what's
happening in ukraine like what do we in
the west not know and not understand
about china that we really should
we in the west started engaging china
really in about the 1990s and
particularly after 2001 when china
entered the world trade organization and
a lot of western companies uh sort of
rushed into china to make some money
we thought that china would be
like japan or like taiwan or like
singapore in a post-world war ii period
that is that
if we engage with china if we help china
get richer and helped its people get
richer
they would see how
they would see the superior superiority
of western systems and they would become
more like us in an asian way like japan
has or south korea has but that china
would essentially follow that path
i think what we didn't realize was that
even though the chinese wanted a big
slice of western prosperity they had
pretty much rejected everything else
the chinese communist party still
remains in power not only that they have
found extremely clever ways of remaining
in power while still getting rich as a
country
and as a result we find ourselves now in
a situation where china truly is the uh
most comprehensive threat to the west
that we're facing really for for two or
three generations
and and john you were talking about the
ingenious ways the ccp managed to hold
on to power what are they
the ccp uh and i have to give them
credit they're very good students of
history because they looked at what
happened in eastern europe and the
soviet union they looked at what
happened in the own country in 1989 when
there were country-wide protests uh
calling for democracy
and what they realized was that
as you get richer as a country as you
industrialize you cannot um alienate
yourself that is if you're at a ruling
party you cannot alienate yourselves
from the rising middle class elites in
fact if you want to remain in power you
have to co-opt to rising middle-class
elites and the lesson they learned from
eastern europe and the soviet union and
also from what happened in the 1980s in
your own country was that if you allow
the emergence of an independent middle
class
that is a middle class that doesn't need
you doesn't need the party for its
prosperity and a security you'll
inevitably lose power so what the
chinese have done since really from the
mid 1990s is that
the party has ensured that it has become
the primary dispenser of
economic and social opportunity in the
country and if you go to china today if
you deal with chinese elites today
chinese elites and the world to do are
the strongest supporters for chinese
communist party which is the opposite of
what happened in the soviet union in
eastern europe and the 1980s uh in the
people's republic of china itself the
elites in china are now
those who want the party to remain in
power because they're the ones that
actually do best uh in in china and
chinese society so from that point of
view the chinese communist party has
been quite
uh clever about it they have engineered
a situation where the future of the
party is tied to the future of elites in
the country and and this is a very
dangerous uh situation for us because
that's not what we thought would happen
uh when we started to engage with china
john when i was in china admittedly it
was about 2000 i think 2006 2007
one thing that surprised me was exactly
what you were saying which in many ways
it's a capitalist paradise
you you can go and you can go to louis
vuitton you can go to all these western
shops and spend all this money on luxury
goods you can have almost a western life
as long as you don't criticize the party
you can enjoy a wonderful capitalist
life it's it's so that's very much the
heart of their success isn't it
well uh it's more than that it's true
that uh if
it's true that there is a people speak
of a social compact that the middle
classes can
buy chanel and in a process they don't
question the political structure
but it's more than that because to get
rich in china you have to be well
connected to the party
you know if you look at the chinese
communist party it is actually the
largest membership organization in the
world there's over 100 million members
and there's an estimated uh
50 to 60 million people lining up to
join or who are put putting applications
to join now why do they do that because
when you join the ccp
um you start getting connections into
the business world into the social world
um you know i've had
uh chinese students who are obviously
part of the elites
that when they write up their cv one of
the first things they put is their
chinese communist party membership
number and they do that because if
you're a ccp member
you are given more privileges more
opportunities
scholarships
clerkships internships into the best
companies it is a paradise if you like
for ccp members
but it is not a paradise for those who
are not cpp members but the irony is
that it's called the chinese communist
party but it is the rich in china who
are joining the chinese communist party
not the poor not the peasants but once
again that is a deliberate
engineered uh social construction in
order to tie the future of these elites
to the future of the ccp
and that is an ingenious way of
maintaining power because you're not
doing it through force which is going to
you know upset people anger people and
quite rightly so you're doing it through
soft power and encouraging people
through by essentially manipulating
their behavior
well you're essentially aligning the
interests and incentives of the rising
classes and the upper classes to
yourself
or you know that is the party
now this has been done before um
you know it's it's not a comparison
often made but here i'm talking just
about the political economic structure
not necessarily the
um the the foreign policy aspects but
the political economic structure of
modern day china it's quite similar to
mussolini's italy or hitler's uh germany
in the sense that the elites
are
very closely aligned to the party are
often members of the party and it's a
very cozy arrangement at the top of
course there are the majority of people
in china who are not doing as well as
those elites but they don't get a say um
that's not how china works so so that is
essentially how um the ccp has remained
in power as the country has got richer
it sounds like john it's basically a
country where the ruling class have a
very strong grip on the country and are
able to dictate very powerfully and very
easily what that country is going to do
now put that together with the comment
you made only a few minutes ago that
china is the biggest threat to the
western generations talk to us about
that because you've got this gigantic
country most of the equipment we're
using to record this is made in that
country we were all told here in the
west that you know it's great we're just
trading and we exchange this and that
and that's wonderful
why do you say china is such a threat to
the west
it's it's a threat to this into the west
both in terms of its capability and its
intention if you look at its capability
yes we know about the growth military
the people's liberation army and it's
it's in in fact uh statistically china
is engaging in the most rapid
re-militarization of any country in
absolute and relative terms in peacetime
history right so that in itself
should should cause you to ask you know
why they doing that but china's not just
a millionaire john sorry to interrupt
sorry to interrupt let me ask you that
question why are they doing that
well they've told us and we should
believe them they want to
initially it was just about taking
taiwan but that was the goal 20 30 years
ago that goal is still there still the
number one goal but now it's about in uh
dominating east china sea which is the
maritime areas they share with japan a
few other countries they claim the whole
the south china sea and they eventually
want to
force not necessarily through war but
but through other coercive means they
want to force the united states out of
east asia and once they've done that
china gets east asia to itself and the
reason why i say that is if you look at
the chinese military budget
it is larger than the combined budgets
of east asia
south asia and oceana so larger than the
combined budgets that all of those
countries in those regions if the united
states is not in in uh asia there is no
balance and the chinese know that so
they they can count
and they and that's why they're doing it
now why they're doing it that's just the
goal that they've had they see
themselves as the
um natural
permanent
dominant power in asia
and they see the americans who
were there after world war ii as the
imposters
um now unfortunately in in
asia there are probably 40 plus
countries very few of those countries
actually want china to dominate which is
why most of those countries are quite
happy for the united states to continue
to maintain its militaries in a region
but that's what china wants it wants to
be the undisputed number one country
and it wants to impose its institutions
and its
uh processes and norms in the region so
i you know that just doesn't that is
irreconcilable with most uh of what we
want most not not just what the west
wants but what most asian countries want
and and hence that's why i consider
china
the
most comprehensive and serious threat
and before i interrupted you you were
going to talk about things other than
their military
buildup what else were you going to
mention
what i was going to say was china's
military buildup has been terrifyingly
impressive
but it's it's economic and technological
uh rise and i should mention on the back
of western know-how and capital but it's
been its economic and technological rise
which
is really the source of its power
because
uh you know we can't we as in the west
or other
asian countries who fear china
nevertheless we cannot treat china like
we treat russia because china is just
far too important to too many countries
it's the largest trading partner of over
100 countries
um
and and so
you know we want to find ways of
constraining china's options and
stopping it from doing certain things
but we can't actually isolate it in the
way that we can isolate russia or as
we're doing now so so that's the sort of
policy in
even sort of it moral dilemma as as to
what it is we should we should do about
china
and john there'd be a lot of people
going you see this is the problem with
globalization is that you all you know
all these interconnected supply chains
you become over-reliant on countries
like china and when they become hostile
or if they become hostile it means that
you are vulnerable to them economically
that
you know i think globalization really
arose in 1990s onwards you know in terms
of the the the enormous interdependence
of countries supply chains markets
capital and so on
and if you think about that period of
history the soviet union had fallen
there was a complacency
in the west and other parts of the world
that essentially ideological differences
don't matter anymore right so
when we welcome china into the global
trading system
when we
help china become such a dominant
player in global supply chains
we didn't think at all about geopolitics
we didn't think at all about a clash of
values we just assumed that all that
mattered was that if we could uh
help the chinese get richer and if we
could benefit from that then everything
would be fine so
you know it's not that globalization has
benefited the world uh immensely but we
forgot to think about
the who it is that we should
um
uh becoming interdependent with you know
who is it that we we can actually trust
essentially we forgot about geopolitics
and and and geopolitics will always come
back to bite
and john uh you i know you watched my
interview with our mutual friend john
anderson and i was making very much the
same point that people in different
countries have different values
surprisingly enough and different
agendas and different ways of doing
things and i can speak a little bit
about what that's
like as a someone who comes from russia
from a child from the perspective of
china when you talk about ideology and
ideological differences can you explain
to people what is it that the ccp want
how are they different from us here in
the west what is this ideology and
ideological divides that you're talking
about
maybe the best way i can sort of
summarize it um and it's not a crude
summary i think it's an accurate one
the chinese communist party is not
communist they're leninist
there's a leninist party and what i mean
by that is
um like all leninist entities and the
highest priorities remain in power and
the way they remain in power is to
utilize all elements of the state
society to ensure they remain in power
so if you think about of the difference
between say a leninist uh entity
compared to a liberal or
liberal democratic one
in for a leninist entity such as chinese
communist party there is really no
distinction between a public and a
private
you know every
aspect of your life
a private firm what would consider
private activity that is fair game if
that helps the party remain in power
then that's allowable if that
doesn't help the party remain in power
then you know that should be banned you
know in recent uh months we had sort of
quite quite a weird spectacle of
xi jinping the chinese leader wanting to
ban
the interest of chinese young
um
teenagers in boy bands right now why do
you want to ban boy bands because he
thought it was making
the the chinese male youth soft and
unprepared for war
right and and the point i'm trying to
make is
you know what i was saying there is no
distinction in a leninist mindset
between a public and a private
everything you do in what we would
consider our private lives our private
businesses and so on uh that's relevant
to whether the party remains in power or
relevant to whether the party loses
power so essentially that's what
modern-day uh chinese communist party
actually is and you know i know to a lot
of people who've been brought up uh
being told that the ccp
ideology doesn't matter they really just
want to get rich
you know don't take my word for it i
invite anyone and it's quite accessible
now read party documents that are now
mandatory learning for all school
children uh in in china they've gone in
a very leninous direction
and in the sense that's kind of what
their roots were they've just returned
to those roots you know and that in
itself makes them
makes the ccp incompatible
to the way we view the world and the
sort of world that we want to to live in
hey kk do you believe in spring cleaning
yes but only when my wife does it in
russia men who clean are executed for
not being real men which is correct well
for those men who are living in the 21st
century manscaped has an incredible
offer for you manscaped are the global
leaders immense below the waist grooming
and have forever changed the grooming
game with their amazing performance
package 4.0
inside this care bundle you'll find the
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker ear
and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop provider turner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your werewolves might look like
a couple of boris johnsons treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology by the
way mate it's father's day around the
corner get me a present because i am the
daddy of trigonometry how about i get
your lawnmower 4.0 for when your
girlfriend dumps you why would i need
one because standards have changed since
we were last on the dating scene once
upon a time you could have a forest
grown down there but it's 2022 and
deforestation is the order of the day
personal grooming isn't just for the
younger man get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger20 at manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with the code
trigger20 at manscape.com it's time to
throw out all your old hygiene habits
and upgrade your life
but authoritarianism brings its advice
its own advantages doesn't it when it
comes to running a country can you
explain why in many ways
although the human rights issues and
everything is obviously awful
actually the way they run the country
it has certain advantages doesn't it
the authoritarian approach
um and most people you know most people
sort of attribute
chinese authoritarianism or the
advantages of chinese authoritarianism
to
in in the economic space
it now if you're a poor country and you
need to
modernize and industrial industrialize
quickly
then yeah if you want to put human
rights aside and put land rights and and
other rights aside authoritarianism
for poor countries it works right in the
sense that you can force a farmer to
give up your land so you can build a
road no need to go to courts or
compensate that farmer right so you you
can do all those things but the problem
is that when society gets richer and
more complex when the economy gets more
complex
that's when authoritarianism suffers so
if you look at china's challenge now and
this is the way they view their own
challenge they've gone from a low income
country to a middle-income country they
want to become a high-income country now
become a high-income country you can't
just
get by on cheap labor or cheap land you
know that largely doesn't exist in
relative terms in china anymore so what
do you have to do you have to innovate
you have to allow people to
experiment you have to allow freedom
association if i want to start a
business with constantine rather than
you i have a right to because
constantine is a better fit
but if a government tells me i can't do
that then obviously there's there's
actual cost to that so the point i'm
trying to make is um authoritarian
countries at the early stages even an
economic sense
um
there are advantages but as you sort of
get more complicated as an economy in
society that's when they really struggle
um and the last thing i'd say about the
supposed authoritarian advantage i mean
look at covert you know when code first
happened
forget about you know the release of
covert wells intentional or not
you know
when when covert first spread throughout
chinese society we saw these really
extreme lockdowns and a lot of people to
my concern in aware said oh wow look how
great the chinese are doing why can't we
be like that and a lot of western
countries actually tried yeah you know
to their shame they actually tried now
look at look at um
look at the situation two years later
you know over time over the we
we've had debates in in uk where you are
in australia about you know how to best
manage this
over time we've cobbled together some
way of living with covet
authoritarian countries like china still
haven't done that you know they're still
basically
uh living as if they're in the first two
months of covert in in 2020. and the
point i'm trying to make is that
authoritarian societies they don't tend
to
adjust they don't tend to recognize
mistakes because no one tells the
government they've made a mistake
people just have to grin and bear it and
sometimes by pure luck
the people get a good deal but over the
course of
history we find that the authoritarian
countries
they are the ones that make massive
mistakes
inflicted on the population because they
don't self-correct in the same way
and the point i thought i mean that was
a great point number one the point that
i thought that was very interesting was
when you talked about innovation and to
me and correct me if i'm wrong john but
to me free speech and innovation go hand
in hand because it's that ability to
question to challenge to play with
accepted norms that's what really leads
to true innovation isn't it
it does china has poured
billions of dollars into trying to
create
you know a chinese silicon valley for
example
it hasn't worked and why hasn't it
worked because
um
they're always trying to pick winners
it's always top down at bottom up
you know
there there is
you don't have the you don't have the
same creative destruction in in in
in an economic sense in in chinese
societies like you do in western
societies and part of breeze and linked
to your free speech comment is that you
don't
even in a business context you know put
aside a human right through a social
context in a business context in china
you don't really have the same
encouragement or sometimes even right to
question the business strategy or the
corporate strategy once it's been
determined on high by political
operatives right so that's that's just
not a particularly good uh way of
innovation
even in terms of um
the flow of capital in china
there's the mass misallocation of
capital because governments are
constantly trying to pick winners and
throwing money at them and when they get
it wrong those companies are not allowed
to fail they just throw more and more
money at those companies so i'm not
denying the chinese have achieved quite
a fair bit but when it comes to
those higher end higher value added
areas of even just economy
china go does nowhere near as well as uh
western and
um
and open societies
and john coming back to the geopolitics
side of this for a moment you talked
earlier about uh china and the ccp
particularly learning lessons from the
soviet experience uh and the the
protests that they saw in in china
itself in in the 80s
what is the situation with china
vis-a-vis what russia is doing in
ukraine now a lot of people myself
included who are not experts thought
that china would jump on on that
distraction as an opportunity to make a
move on taiwan they they they have
supported russia but not as overtly as
some people thought what has been their
response what other lessons they're
learning from it and what do you think
they're planning to do as a result
if if you remember
you know xi jinping went to moscow and
about two two or three weeks before the
russian invasion declared a no limits
pact with vladimir putin
now at the time
china and russia and
the american and western intelligence
for that matter
um were off the view that if russia
invaded
ukraine would forward in three four days
right so
at that time china believed that this
was a real moment in history
um that you know if if you look at a lot
of the chinese
documents and and
proclamations at the time
they were talking
using phrases like the great unseen
changes in history what they were
talking about was that we're entering a
turning point in history
where the west led by a dysfunctional
united states
were on the wane and that the
authoritarian societies who were far
more determined and organized were on
the rise
so
china thought the russians would invade
ukraine they would achieve victory
relatively quickly and then this would
lower the courage and resolve
in
not just united states but but in asian
countries if china tried to do the same
with taiwan now obviously ukraine hasn't
played out that way and and the chinese
now are quite honestly quite um
stumped as to as to what to do about it
because what they've realized now is
that one it's not that easy to
defeat even a smaller enemy
um who has the determination to fight
because it's their existential existence
in you know in question
the second thing they've they've worked
out is that
when you start
killing people which the russians did to
ukrainians
the west
sometimes will actually unite now it's
true that the west hasn't you know sent
any troops to to ukraine no western
soldiers or american or nato soldiers
have actually died
but the coordination of sanctions
against russia
have shocked the chinese
and unlike russia china cannot afford to
have a basket case economy
if it does the regime in china falls
right and china is still hugely
dependent on not just western markets
and technology but on
access to western finance and western
payment systems the american dollar and
so on so what really freaks the chinese
out
if you had to point to one thing that
freaks the chinese out it's that if the
americans decided to cut chinese
entities off from transacting in a us
dollar the chinese financial system
would fold tomorrow
um and
the us have shown that they they can do
that they've done that to it to a
limited degree with the russians and
they would certainly do that to the
chinese if there was a war say over
taiwan
so the silver lining i mean you know
putting aside the tragedies occurring in
ukraine and the life lost lost there but
the silver lining you know in terms of
the china story is that
uh it has given china
um reason to pause
and from a
policy point of view i think we have
probably bought ourselves quite a few
years in terms of any chinese invasion
or intended invasion of taiwan
and john f for those of us who are again
not experts i think it's not unhelpful
to understand what is the reason that
china is so focused on taiwan uh why is
it such a key
core plan part of the plan why is it
it's almost feels like when i hear
people talk about it's like a deeply
emotive issue for for the chinese
leadership also can you just delve into
the history of that a little bit for us
it is a deeply emotive issue and and and
it really stems from the civil war in
china the communists under mao zedong
defeated the nationalists uh who were
led by zheng kai-shek
uh shankar sheikh fled to taiwan and you
know as as as you uh
you probably remember
um there was a period of time where the
world trying to decide you know who was
the real china was it the people's
republic of china based in beijing or
was it the republic of china based in
taipei now most people now recognize the
people's republic of china as
you know d china but nevertheless do not
want taiwan to be um subjugated or
integrated into mainland china now from
the chinese communist party's point of
view this is one of those
unfinished business issues that that
it's it's it's somewhat irrational in
the sense that the amount of resources
they put into
you know
into preparing to take taiwan is
irrational
um even though taiwan has huge strategic
value but you know nevertheless the fact
that it's the number one priority of for
the chinese communist party it's one of
those
somewhat irrational things but it's just
uh
stems from
um uh i i guess the the period of
history of civil war and this notion
unfinished business the last thing i
would say is that
in the 90s and early 2000s
you know the chinese always wanted
taiwan but
what's changed in the last 10 years is
that you've now got a leader xi jinping
who has staked his
capacity to be president for life
uh amongst other things on taking taiwan
right that's never happened before you
know when you look at xi jinping's
predecessors they sort of just said we
want taiwan but
let future generations
decide you know work it out how we
actually get taiwan xi jinping's the
first leader to actually say he wants to
resolve the taiwan question and
in in in his time and that it cannot be
left unresolved so for for a leader to
stake his
um
his uh claim to be leader for life on
taiwan which he has done that's what
makes it quite dangerous
but isn't that a very high risk strategy
john because you know
if he doesn't make that happen isn't
that going to weaken his position
absolutely which makes him even more
desperate
look i i personally think's
miscalculation by him and i think was
born out of hubris right i mean he
overestimated i think both
um
the
chinese
um
uh
both chinese power and influence on the
one hand and the resolve of other
countries on the other
um look i wouldn't want to be xi jinping
i mean to to
i i should say i i should step back and
say that xi jinping is now the most
powerful chinese leader since mao zedong
um you know he has truly centralized
power around himself and that's not what
his predecessors did they used to
centralize power around a group of
people but xi jinping has become
essentially
um a classical
um dictator
uh now to to achieve that he has had to
do a lot of uh
terrible things he's for example he's
had to
put you know more than a million
chinese communist party officials in
jail who were his enemies
you know he's had to promise the world
to the country that he's not only taking
taiwan but that he would use belt and
road initiative to
allow china to dominate the entire
region and so on
now when you make those sorts of
promises and you've got a lot of people
gunning for your fall you know you you
you tend to become dangerous and
desperate so so i think that's
jason ping has certainly added an extra
layer of um risk
in terms of what might happen with china
in the future
and let's let's delve into the human
rights issues with china because
i don't think when people who live in
the west they grew up in the west really
understands what it means to grow up and
live in a place like china so what is it
like for people
to live in china what happens if you
criticize a regime and you've used the
word go to jail but what does that
actually mean again
well i mean
you know obviously there are
the human rights abusers going going
against certain
ethnicities um and people such as the
uyghurs and tibetans right so that's
just your
um not to make light of it that's your
garden variety
um
uh genocide right cultural genocide and
and in some cases human genocide exactly
and again
i'll interrupt again apologies but just
because this is an issue we all talk
about but we probably have no idea about
why are the chinese doing that
the chinese um
when mouse is doing one power in 1949
within the three years he had invaded
both xinjiang which is where the uyghurs
are and tibet which are you know largely
buddhist
the chinese have an intolerance for
differences and once again it's a very
leninous
mindset
the uyghurs want to that we just don't
necessarily want to separate from
people's republic of china but they want
to live life the way they want to live
life
you know they don't want the chinese
communist party to be the central part
of their lives same tibetans
and the uh chinese communist party
cannot tolerate that
right i mean it's it's it's a strange
notion to us because you know for most
of us living in liberal societies we
can't just say well they want to live
that way that's their business right who
cares but
for leninist political organizations
they cannot tolerate
um groups of people who refuse to submit
to the rules that are being imposed upon
them so so that's that's
you know it's really as simple as that
and and
in the same way that a lot of the
um
cultural chauvinistic attitudes led to
uh the second world war i mean those
attitudes exist
in the chinese communist party right i
mean
um that's just a fact i mean it's it's
documented and they're quite open about
it in fact they just don't tolerate uh
cultural differences which they see is a
threat to their power no one else does
but they see is a threat to the power
but on the human rights question okay
there's that element but in terms of
what it's like to for a normal harmed
chinese person not in these regions but
say in shanghai or whatever
um
look you know normally you you sort of
go about your life
you so you sort of know what not to talk
about you've internalized you know where
the where the sort of boundaries are
um and in fact you often become quite
critical of those who might want to
cross those boundaries because then it
disrupts
the flow of things
sounds like living in the west john i'm
going to be honest with you
well i mean at least at least we can
have podcasts like this right yeah yeah
in the west um
but there has been a sort of more
of a well and turn to things over the
last 10 years with the social
surveillance
you know i'm talking about technology
such as facial recognition
ai being used to actually um
predict or work out uh crimes that
you're about to commit
um a social credit system where if you
don't hang around the right people or
you read the wrong books you lose social
credit points and if you lose social
credit points
you know you may not actually get a spot
in university or get a scholarship or
um you may not actually get that job you
know at that state-owned enterprise or
whatever so there has been a sort of
far darker
high-tech turn to
the um suppression that is going on in
china um but you know for most people i
think in china they're not
they
they just sort of know where the
boundaries are and they go about their
lives it's not it's not necessarily that
they are
uh you know chanting communist slogans
every day but they just know what not to
do
hey francis what do you think is the
best way to advertise a business that's
easy all you need to do is spend shed
loads of cash on an advert that's going
to be promoted on a dying medium like tv
then simply sit back and watch all your
hard-earned money disappear down the
toilet what about advertising with
trigonometry why would i do that when i
can advertise on itv3 for the measly sum
of 20 grand and be watched by six people
because trigonometry now has over 350
000 subscribers across the different
platforms and gets two million views and
downloads a month that's right you can
place an advert with us and we'll
promote your brand on one of our
episodes your ad will be written by two
professional comedians yeah that's right
we're hiring two professional comedians
we make our ads funny and engaging to
the point where some people say the ads
are their favorite parts of the show
yeah we probably shouldn't admit that
mate all you need to do is contact us on
marketing at triggerpod.co.u
that's marketing at triggerpod.co.uk
advertise with us and we'll get your
business cancelled
okay so what are the rules in communist
china then john what if i go over there
or if i live there what are the golden
rules of what not to do
you don't criticize the party you don't
criticize individuals within the party
you don't criticize party policies even
um and otherwise everything else is fine
what about jokes what about humor am i
allowed to mock them am i allowed to no
no no no so no you're not you're not
allowed to make jokes you know that to
denigrate the party or individuals
within it
um
but you know it's it's i don't want to
give the impression that it's just about
what you should not do there are still
things you ought to do so for example
um if the party says that
you should buy
local government bonds
to support
you know indebted local government
companies then you're obliged to do it
now if you don't do it you don't go to
jail but then you know you may not
actually get access to other privileges
even in an economic sense so
it's it's there are all sorts of um
um
positive and negative rules that you
have to abide by and
you know i guess for a lot of chinese
citizens
they probably don't think about it
anymore they just sort of do it because
they kind of know what it is they meant
to do to stay out of trouble now for a
lot of people living there i'm sure they
probably think you know that's
i can live with that i mean that's just
what that it is better than what it was
than you know the grandparents
generation for example but for us uh
it's not something we can tolerate but
finally from a foreign policy
perspective why that matters is that
china is trying to impose some of these
rules and standards on neighbouring
countries and that's kind of where
um the clash comes because you know no
country is really telling the chinese
communist party how to run their own
country
the problems are occurring now because
the chinese communist party are now
telling other countries
how they should run their systems and
political economies
so i think that's that's sort of where
the that's where we're at at the moment
that's why china's such a problem
could you give an example of that please
john where the chinese are starting to
dictate in their region
how countries should be run
well let me give you an example from my
country australia australia is entering
its third year of
a cascading series of economic
punishments against us you know china
was our number one trading party and
that china still is our number one
trading partner now
if you look at why china is punishing
australia and the chinese have been
quite helpful because in november last
year they actually released
a list of 14 grievances
and the list of 14 grievances was this
is what australia has to do for china to
stop punishing your country and if you
look down the list of 14 grievances
uh nine out of 14 grievances concerned
our domestic policy so you know there
were foreign policy aspects like we
shouldn't criticize
uh tibet policies in tibet and xinjiang
and hong kong we shouldn't talk about
hong kong anymore we should not care
about the south china sea but even if we
did all that
most of the demands made against us were
things like
the government is funding think tanks
that are critical of china and that has
to stop
the media in australia is critical to
china and the government has to stop it
the government's own internal processes
for foreign investment is too harsh and
needs to change
the government has banned
various companies from entering certain
sectors such as far away from entering
our 5g sector
and that is not acceptable to china so
this is an example where you know it's
not just china saying to us shut up
about xinjiang
they're saying in australia in your own
country this is what you must do
you know for relations to
be on to be stable and and proceeding
smoothly
australia's not the only one they've
done that to um they've done that to um
um they tried to japan they tried
they've done it tried to do vietnam they
tried to do it to a whole a handful of
countries in southeast asia
um
you know no self-respecting country
would accept those sorts of terms
so that's what i'm talking about
it's very interesting and how
just very quickly uh we've seen the
impact of chinese power in chinese money
beyond actually the region
so for example when nba players speak
out in support of china or things of
that nature what do you make of how
china is responding or playing part in
the western culture wars and and all of
that side of things when you've got
uh chinese uh kind of saying that
america is a deeply racist society
while putting uyghurs in concentration
camps like is china playing a clever a
clever part in all of that do you think
or
or what what is your view of that
i thought they were initially playing
quite a subtle clever game so you know
examples of the nba um
[Music]
you gave i mean other examples are uh
you know hollywood movies you know you
you know it's in hollywood movies the
villains are never chinese they're
always russian yeah right
and a reason because hollywood is racist
against my people
but but you know i mean i i guess what i
was saying was in a recent past china
played a more subtle game in
just
um
delivering economic incentives
for governments and countries to do
things in a way that they wanted without
being too overt about it
it's in the last two or three years
where i think
um
that has become a lot more the chinese
have become a lot more forthright so
they're now
demanding things that other governments
should do
you know they're now
on a daily basis not daily but on a
constant basis threatening other
governments
the most recent example is new zealand
you have the new zealand leader
uh prime minister aden who's currently
in washington having talks with joe
biden
she made a fairly standard comment
expressing concerned about um
some of china's economic and social
policies you know like it was nothing
really that other countries don't really
say and how did china respond
the foreign ministry basically
threatened to
in their words treat new zealand like we
are now treating australia right i mean
that sort of heavy-handed approach
um to be frank it's made it
quite easy for leaders in the west now
to sell the proposition that china is a
problem and in which we need to
uh design policies to to deal with it
and john that that posturing is that a
sign of china's growing strength and
financial power or is it a sign of them
of their weakness that they that they
feel that they're under attack and that
they need to hit back
look the chinese certainly
um
[Music]
my view is that in the last
four or five years the chinese as
powerful as they are they've
overestimated their strengths
so they thought that
you know i mentioned i mentioned the
phrase the great unseen changes
um
in in in several centuries you know
that's a very common phrase used from xi
jinping down
to refer to great changes in the power
in the distribution of global power are
happening now and it's in china's favor
so for the last three or four years i
think there's been a lot of
overestimation by the chinese of their
own strengths
and look to be fair to them i think they
they
overestimate their strength because
until quite recently much of the world
really just bowed down to china every
time china demanded something you know
it's really only been the last two years
or so where
countries have sort of said enough and
we'll just
uh absorb whatever punishments that
china is going to deliver to us
um so china has in my view china has
been conditioned to behave like this
and it's not working now but
um
because they've been doing for so long
and it's actually worked for so long
that's the kind of method that they know
so you know when a smaller country which
is basically a real country except the
united states does something
that's how china responds because for
about 10 years it's worked it's only the
last two years it hasn't
and the last two years i presume that a
lot of that has to do with covert and
the chinese attitudes to coverts and the
way they've been to put it mildly less
than clear with what happened
uh i i think that's created a lot of
anger um
but you know i i think what happened
with covert in terms of the spread of
covert and
the seat that tried to cover up the
spread of covert which you know allowed
it to spread around the world
i think most people understand that
that's indicative of the nature of the
chinese system right i mean it wasn't
just one stuff up like what happened
with covert is
uh indicative of how the chinese system
actually works so i i think i think that
has changed views um another thing that
that's occurred and look i have to you
know regardless of what your viewers
think of him donald trump had a huge
impact
you know no president and of the
american president has the loudest
platform in the world
as we know and donald trump was the man
um
no american president
certainly in in my lifetime had called
out china in that way
and even though you know in many ways he
was a very difficult
in some ways a poor president
he changed the conversation about china
you know certainly in allied countries
like australia
um but but i i also think in in some
parts of the world and that it won't
admit it even some parts like europe for
example i think it changed the
conversation like china like everyone
knew china did
the things that um the trump
administration accused china of doing
that to call it out so publicly and make
that the focus of diplomatic
conversation is actually quite a
different thing
um and and so i i think that actually
had you know and i was in government at
the time so i could see it from the
inside that had quite a big impact on
how the world started to speak and think
about china certainly the western world
anyway
was and speaking of the western world to
wrap things up before we go to our own
final question and questions from our
local supporters been a great interview
really enjoyed having you on the show
john i suppose the real question that
we're all asking is based on everything
you've said
what should be the west's response and
attitude to china going forward you
mentioned that we've bought ourselves a
few years or mr putin bought us a few
years in terms of taiwan and putting
that off how should the west act to have
i think most people in the west would
like to have a constructive relationship
with china if they could
but they also don't want to expose
ourselves to the same vulnerabilities
that perhaps we have done with russia
where we embolden somebody to to feel
that they can do things that we wouldn't
want them to do so what should be our
posture
doing nothing or doing little will
actually make things worse because china
is set on the direction that it wants to
go right i mean
uh this is not a statement of ideology
it's a statement of observation
and
i believe what
when a communist child
the chinese communist party and xi
jinping tells you what they want to do
it's a wise thing to actually believe
them
and they've told us what they want to do
so my point is that
the only way to
to get to a relatively happy outcome
is to restrain and deter
right i mean
doing the opposite actually gets you to
a worse position because it just allows
the chinese to
um
push boundaries that eventually will
lead to you know a a a much worse
situation so i i think that's
that's
the way we should look at it i mean we
are now dealing with a
large power that has fundamentally
different um
not just objectives but
values and outlooks on where things
ought to be than we do
um and and so we have to understand that
that that the other thing i would say is
and
i'm lucky that i'm just old enough to
remember
the cold war
you know i was a child but i'm just old
enough to actually remember it and
understand elements of it
and
there are
ideological and ethical differences
between governments
right and um
and differences in in the sense that it
it leads to
the sorts of conflicts that we read
about in history books our objective is
to obviously avoid those
and if you want to be a student of
history if if you look at the
the period leading up to the 1940s a lot
of people describe the current period as
like the 1930s
uh if you go back in history i mean
you know
there were things that we could have
done
to
to uh
disincentivize certain governments from
doing certain things we didn't do those
things i do think even though no
historical period exactly the same i do
think we're in quite a similar period
i'm optimistic that there's time to
actually do that and
i feel much better about where things
are
um than i was four or five years ago
where i think we're sort of sleep
walking our way to disaster so from that
point of view i i do think
um
we do have good options
to dissuade the chinese from doing the
sorts of things that would be a
catastrophe
dr john lee it has been an absolute
pleasure uh we're gonna do like
constantin said our locals at the end of
the interview but we always finish with
our final question which is what is the
one thing we're not talking about that
we really should
be don't lose confidence in our own
institutions and values i mean i i say
this as a typical immigrant who went
from
um you know i was born in malaysia but i
say it has a typical immigrant whose
family deliberately left the country to
go to what they thought was a better
country
and what makes that better country are
the institutions and the sorts of values
behind it
it's you know it's really frustrating
for
i'm talking about my australian
experience and the american one where i
spend a lot of time there it's really
frustrating for
an immigrant into these societies to
watch people in the west beat themselves
up over
things that not just don't matter but
actually create divisions when they when
it when when they don't actually exist
um you know the west doesn't have a
natural right to succeed
we do have to make sure that
that the basic principles of liberalism
that that we
that we based our institutions and our
processes on they have to continue to
remain and that's not the
uh nature of fashion right now
but we do have to be careful in the west
about you know
where we're going because
in 20 30 40 years we don't necessarily
have a right to um still be vibrant
societies
well said it's something francis and i
uh in our
far less articulate way have been trying
to remind people of as well uh here in
the west uh but we really appreciate you
joining us where can people follow your
work
and keep up with the things that you're
putting out
i look the the best way is just to uh
look at my profiles and hudson institute
and that really has most of my stuff
there um so if you look at my name
johnny at the hudson institute
most of my stuff will be there
dr john lee we're going to ask you some
locals questions in a second but for now
thank you so much for joining us we
really appreciate it and thank you all
for watching and listening we'll see you
very soon with another brilliant episode
like this one or raw show all of them go
out at 7pm uk time and for those of you
who like your trigonometry on the go
it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys
identity politics is the worst thing
it's cool that is happening in the west
i mean it is just
tearing ourselves apart i mean and for
no you know
reason
[Music]
[Applause]
you